Jeff of the cards we have chosen from
the story engine decks what do you think
the premise would be with our story here
well
I'm I wouldn't know what to come up with
as a premise at this point
because
it's so wide open in terms of
possibilities
and
each new story idea comes to you in a
different way
and sometimes there's a premise built
right into it from the beginning
like in the live training I'm doing now
with people five days a week we're
building a romantic comedy
and the idea that I came up with was one
of my favorite movies which is uh my
favorite year with Peter O'Toole
directed by Richard Benjamin
it's about a drunken movie star and this
guy has to babysit him while he's in
town to be part of the Sid Caesar show
based on a true story with Errol Flynn
and it's a great movie Peter O'Toole is
amazing in it
and
I thought well so
if this guy has to babysit
uh this this actor
it's a
and the actor's about to get thrown out
of the country so the woman who's
babysitting him kind of a corporate I
can get it done type to keep him from
getting thrown out of the country she
marries him
and so it was
My Favorite Year meets The Proposal
and I was like
that's we can have fun with that and you
can like see the premise in it right
away
like it's kind of sitting there
whereas this is more just like somebody
dumped a a Lego set out on the floor
and you could build anything out of it
you know from like a mermaid to a
warship to a a castle to you know a meal
and it's like you could and this feels
like that it's
it's really Dynamic it has a real kind
of Philip K dick warp to it or
no it's susceptible to having a Philip K
dick Warp
incorporated into it
um
and it also reminds me of
uh
the Alfred bester book The Stars my
destination
which is considered one of the top
science fiction books of all time but in
it there's a robot that's a bartender it
looks like an 1890s
kind of Steampunk robot but it's
no one of the characters is radioactive
in the story and he can only be around
people for like 29 minutes at a time
and he's in the room they're having a
really high level meeting toward the end
of the story and this guy comes in who's
radioactive and they're really getting
down to brass tacks trying to pressure
the main character into doing something
and his radioactivity sets up sets off
the robot Who's the bartender who's
serving them drinks and the the robot
starts
getting whacked out and the main
character asks poses a question to the
robot and it comes up with an
interesting answer
because of the radioactivity
so there's
there's
um
Dynamic possibilities in that and it
reminds me of an Alfred bester short
story called fonly Fahrenheit
where the sky has a
very high level robot that can
paint like Michelangelo you know write
poetry like Lord Byron whatever and like
it can do anything and he can hire it
out and make great money
but something goes wrong with it and it
goes crazy and it kills a little girl so
then he has to go to a different planet
and they're looking for you know like
this super high-end robot
so he
makes its capabilities less it can still
go out and make money for him but it
can't sculpt like Michelangelo anymore
because they'll find him right away and
then it kills somebody else so he keeps
going on the run with the robot he can't
enable it to do as much
and the robot it turns out is
overheating and starts doing this kind
of schizoid dance where it's like
dancing a Rumba and chanting and it's
just and so that like a a radioactive
robot or there's so many
whacked out things you can do to a robot
that it's very suggestive
you know when a robot wants to steal
treachery
a death
um
so
there isn't so much like a premise
shaping up as just one possible kind of
warped Direction
based on my own science fiction
uh Tendencies or
the things that I enjoy in a story
I think that I would
want to look at the 36 dramatic
situations for a minute
because it
it is a spectrum of possibilities
the other thing is that
as I'm looking ahead to
exploring the Enneagram as possibilities
for this story
to what degree
does
an automaton have
the full spectrum of emotional
complexity that a human has and
obviously even as I'm saying that I'm
thinking well it's an AI and they can
build all that stuff in these days
but
you know does the robot have a warped
sense of the way the world works because
his father used to beat him or something
it's like at what point does
personal history not exist
or you know and then of course on the
other hand you have the Tyrell
Corporation where Tyrell says we gift
them with memories so that they it makes
them easier to control because
they don't perceive that they're dying
in two years and they have to fight that
they there's
their emotions it says it gives them a
cushion
um
so all that is possible right and in
fact the better
it can be done the more potentially
scary this robot can be or more heroic
this robot could be depending and it
could be both at the same time
and there you get into the element of
dilemma like
is the robot programmed secretly
programmed for treachery
even while it acts
wonderful and enlightened and
polite
like C-3PO or something
whereas R2D2 will freaking laser you
into dust if that's what it takes
whereas c3p would be like are you sure
that's quite polite or to to vaporize
that fellow
so that the the
um
competing
commands
in the robots programming and can create
an intriguing dilemma
and
the more complexity of personality and
character that the robot has
the more compelling the story can
potentially be
now we could possibly pull another agent
card if we wanted to bring in let's say
a b character and maybe some of the
moral dilemma would fall on that
character maybe because they're uh not
an AI and they they no I would want the
I would want the Dilemma to be
to to be in the protagonist okay all
right but we still need a good strong
villain we definitely need other players
but
we're
approaching this in an interesting way
that we have
a handful of dynamic elements
and as and I think that the 36 dramatic
situations will be useful I'll pull that
out in a minute it's things like
ambition Madness disaster
those kind of things
and I think that
as
some possibilities begin to
gel
that will inform choices for a good
strong antagonist
in other words the story will help
Define who the best protagonist might be
and other main characters as well